[Music]
on a spring day 10 years ago a 41 year
old australian man named julian assange
dressed up as a motorcycle delivery man
he dyed his hair put colored contacts in
his eyes and even put a rock in his shoe
so that he would walk differently than
normal he was sure he was being followed
by dark government forces that were
attempting to capture him and sent him
to the united states to be locked up
he showed up here
to the embassy of ecuador in central
london
once inside this embassy he wouldn't be
on british soil anymore
no one could barge in here and grab him
he'd be safe
it's called political asylum
oh and by the way this isn't actual
footage of julian assange in 2012.
action
you're great
this is an actor we did a reenactment of
this whole thing anyway
assange did make it inside that day and
after entering the ecuadorian embassy in
london he wouldn't leave it for seven
years testing123
i've been
looking at a lot of
this
i've actually started hanging up the
documents over here
because they've been taking up too much
space
i want to tell you the story of julian
assange this guy's a traitor
this is a blow to transparency and a
blow to a free press what this story is
is like a an expression of a new kind of
power the power of
secrets of information an anti-war
online organization attacking u.s policy
in afghanistan and the reason i'm
calling what julian assange does power
is because the u.s is trying to lock him
up for 175 years because of what he did
it's all here in this indictment
the most powerful country in the world
feels threatened by this man and what
he's done i want to take you through
julian assange's story and then to
unpack why the united states is trying
to lock him up for the rest of his life
and i want to persuade you that no
matter what you think of julian assange
and his conduct and his ethics and his
mission
this case should not be ignored
illegally
get assange to sweden and hang on
[Music]
you never know what the outcome is but
the truth is always the best place to
start
[Music]
okay wait before we dive into this video
i want to thank today's sponsor because
the sponsors are the people who make
these videos possible allow me to do
this as my job thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video if you don't
know what a vpn is
it's kind of just like an all-around
protective tool that you don't actually
see or interact with very much it works
in the background a vpn allows you to
connect to the internet but via a
different country so that you can
encrypt and protect your
connection but also so that you can
access things that you might not be able
to access in your country an example is
entertainment like there are things
available in the uk on netflix that are
not available here in the us but with a
vpn i can connect and get access to all
of that content also it works the other
way i'm traveling a lot more lately and
when i'm in a different country my
computer and all the things i'm logged
into kind of freak out because they
think i'm like a hacker from somewhere
else so i connect to a server in the
united states and my internet thinks i'm
in the united states and they don't kick
me out of like my gmail it's not
complicated to connect you don't have to
be like technical or like understand how
it works you just press a button and
you're connected oh and recently nordvpn
is not just a vpn anymore they have this
whole new threat protection system it
blocks malware it blocks trackers it
blocks malicious ads it allows you to
surf the internet much more safely this
is a very affordable tool and if you
want to get in on it do us both a favor
and go to
nordvpn.com johnny harris where you can
get an exclusive deal to get a great
deal on a vpn oh and the best part is if
you don't like it or if it's not useful
to you you can get your money back
within 30 days so go check it out go see
if it works for your life makes your
life better nordvpn.com johnny harris
thank you nordvpn for supporting the
videos that i do
i really appreciate it now let's get
back into the story
[Applause]
okay let's get up to speed really
quickly on who this guy even is and how
he ended up trapped in an embassy in
london julian assange is an australian
hacker who spent most of his life
breaking into computers and getting his
hands on information that he wasn't
supposed to see but that he believed the
world should see
when he was 35 he built a website where
whistleblowers of all kinds could upload
sensitive information that he julian
assange on his new website would publish
and the upside of all of this was that
these whistleblowers would remain
totally anonymous he claimed that even
he wouldn't know who his sources were so
that was 2006 julian assange builds
wikileaks and soon after he starts
receiving submissions like people start
giving him documents that are supposed
to be secret and he starts publishing
them everything from drone strikes in
yemen to oil scandals in peru to
corruption in the arab world tibetan
uprisings in china leaks like this sort
of seem common to us now but this was
like 2007. wikileaks was a totally new
thing it was this open source
intelligence website acting in the name
of no government with no location but
with this very idealistic vision of
making the world's information totally
transparent exposing corruption
exposing
but wikileaks wasn't really noticed
until 2010 when something happened that
would change everything
[Music]
in iraq there was a 22 year old american
intelligence analyst named chelsea
manning horrified by what she was seeing
she decided to download hundreds of
thousands of classified documents from
military computers
and upload them directly to wikileaks
[Music]
of course our top story this morning the
white house blasting the release of over
90 000 u.s military records
the biggest leak in history and this is
the stuff we've been looking through
over the past few weeks hundreds of
thousands of classified documents
containing never-before-seen details on
how the us conducts its war its
diplomacy its intelligence
i mean let me show you some of this
stuff
[Music]
now let me just do a quick disclaimer
here
going through these leaks there is a lot
of like horrific stuff like
stuff i just don't even want to talk
about here or go over it kind of in
vague terms and let you go read the rest
but war is horrible
and what these documents reveal is like
a detailed version of that my fellow
citizens
at this hour american and coalition
forces are in the early stages of
military operations to disarm iraq to
free its people
and to defend the world from grave
danger in these leaks we learn about
secret raids we read about scenes of us
military people
executing iraqi families
we also get a lot of data
the us military claimed that it wasn't
keeping track of deaths in iraq but
these leaks showed that they actually
were and that the number of casualties
including
civilian deaths was actually way higher
than anyone thought before
[Music]
the leaks also revealed this classified
footage that again i'm not going to show
all of it here or even the worst part
keep walking by and one of them has a
weapon development how bad white things
that's a weapon it shows a u.s
helicopter firing on a group of iraqis
who they thought were insurgents but was
really just a family including children
walking with two reuters journalists
[Music]
they were carrying cameras not guns
[Music]
and yet in this video
you see them open fire on these people
uh you know three two engage over
one state line uh let me know when you
gather
light them all up
come on
[Music]
oh yeah look at those dead bastards
nicely
for bringing their kids that's right
[Applause]
you read about this scene where an
apache helicopter is flying over some
insurgents in a house who are
surrendering they're coming out of their
house with their hands up and yet the
apache helicopter
gets the clearance to fire on them and
their justification is according to this
leaked log you're not allowed to
surrender to aircraft they're still
valid targets i mean it's horrendous
as a journalist i'm skeptical i'm like
okay with these like two or three bad
apples is this what we're staring at
but no through these leaks you see that
15 000 civilians were killed in
previously unknown incidents fifteen
thousand these documents reveal
a culture and a system of abuse and
torture in iraq
mostly by the iraqi military and army
that the u.s military knew about but did
nothing to solve and the only reason why
we know about it now
is because chelsea manning gave
wikileaks all of these documents
there's one department of state league
from the embassy in belgium that shows
that the us
tried to pressure belgium into taking
some of the prisoners from guantanamo
bay in order to curry favor with the us
you see the u.s being like hey belgium
take some of these guantanamo prisoners
it's a low-cost way for belgium to
attain prominence in europe like it's
backroom deals
exchanging guantanamo prisoners
for political favors we would have not
known any of this
had these leaks not come out all of this
turned out to be a very grim insight
into how the us is conducting its wars
and unsurprisingly after these giant
leaks came out in 2010 and 2011 on
wikileaks the pentagon was furious this
was dumped on us like it was dumped on
you all sunday night it is the role of
good journalism to take on powerful
abuses and when powerful abuses are
taken on there is always a back reaction
julian assange's website had gone from
being a small hacker website with some
leaks to something that now had
worldwide attention this isn't a wiki
leak this is a wiki torrent these
documents have generated a mix of
reactions from horrified to appalled and
assange himself became the public face
for this and he became really polarizing
he was either praised as a courageous
journalist the role that julian assange
has played in exposing uncomfortable
truths is something that he should be
very proud of wikileaks is no different
from the new york times he just believes
in justice believes in honesty believes
in exposing governments or he was
reproached and condemned as a villain
who was set on damaging the u.s security
interest and putting people in danger in
the process i hope he rocked in hell
starting out this guy's a traitor a
treasonous and and he has broken every
law of the united states illegally shoot
the son of a but regardless of what the
public thought about him the reality is
the u.s government now felt like they
were at war with julian assange and
wikileaks the united states strongly
condemns the illegal disclosure
of classified information there have
been examples in history in which
official conduct has been made public
in the name of exposing wrongdoings or
misdeeds
this is not one of those cases and the
next chapter of his life would be spent
trying to avoid being sent to the u.s to
face them and this is why julian assange
went to the ecuadorian embassy in london
okay so after this huge leak it's now
like 2012. assange is living in london
and he's actually facing the possibility
of being sent to sweden to face an
investigation into sexual misconduct
allegations and even though this sweden
investigation legally has nothing to do
with the big leaking thing that he had
done assange was convinced that the uk
and sweden were working with the us to
try to get assange back onto u.s soil to
face trial so instead of go and
participate in the investigation he fled
to seek political asylum inside the
walls of this embassy
an embassy is kind of like a little
enclave within a country like this is a
little slice of ecuador within london so
the uk couldn't do anything they
couldn't go storm into an embassy so
instead they just positioned a ton of
police outside of the embassy
[Music]
and this is the moment this spectacle of
all these police sitting outside of the
embassy where you realize that this is a
huge deal on paper this was actually a
really small deal the u.s wanted to
arrest assange to send him to sweden to
face this sexual misconduct
investigation but all of this shows us
that this is not about a small
investigation in sweden the u.s wanted
assange to punish him for what he did
and the uk
it was looking like was ready to help
them so while assange is in the walls of
this embassy he's protected and the u.s
would have to wait him out
building their case
but wait a minute hold on
what exactly are we charging assange
with here he published a bunch of leaked
documents so what's the crime here and
honestly that is the heart of this story
what crime did he commit i'm going to
get there i want to just finish the
story of what happens next
julian assange is in an embassy in
london the weeks turn into months and
the months turn into years
and julian assange is living in an
embassy not leaving he occasionally
comes out onto this balcony to deliver a
speech to his increasingly large support
base can you hear me
but like this guy is confined to the
embassy right i joke that's a little bit
like living in a space station because
there's no natural light and there's
you've got to make all your own stuff
and you can't go out to shops and
so on from the embassy assange continues
to run wikileaks he publishes troves of
secret documents it is from the embassy
that he declares his hate for hillary
clinton the american liberal press uh in
falling over themselves uh to defend
hillary clinton are erecting a demon
that is going to put nooses around
everyone's necks and it is here that he
orchestrates a plan to damage her
campaign by strategically publishing
emails that were stolen from the
democratic party and from clinton's
campaign chair john podesta wikileaks
posted these emails in daily batches
throughout october 2016 a month before
the election soon mounting evidence
showed that wikileaks got these emails
potentially unknowingly from a russian
government agent who like assange was
trying to damage the clinton campaign
the leaked emails helped the trump
campaign and quickly made assange an
enemy of american progressives who had
tended to support assange and wikileaks
because they were keeping the government
and the military accountable but now
they hated them wikileaks i love
wikileaks so now it's 2017 and trump is
president because wikileaks is
unbelievable assange is still in the
embassy and from the embassy assange and
wikileaks drop another huge leak this
time of cia documents it revealed the
playbook of the cia's cyber warfare
strategy releasing all of these
documents had one major result making
all of the cia's tools completely
worthless trump who had praised
wikileaks for like helping him get
elected now hated wikileaks
i know nothing about wikileaks it's not
my thing wikileaks walks like a hostile
intelligence service and talks like a
hostile intelligence service so by 2019
julian assange is still in the embassy
and now he's pissed off everyone for one
reason or another it's at this time that
the trump administration starts to
really get serious about how do we get
this guy and how do we punish him
severely for what he's done they start
upping the ante on their case against
julian assange but assange starts to get
really restless in the embassy i mean
can you blame him it's been like seven
years he starts to mistrust his hosts
and in turn his hosts the ecuadorian
diplomats are getting kind of tired of
him his poor hygiene his habit of
playing football in the hallways
meanwhile ecuador's new president is
like less sympathetic to wikileaks
because he was actually the subject of
some embarrassing leaks himself he
actually called assange a miserable
hacker whose only goal is to destabilize
governments and so
they kicked him out
[Music]
the british police were seemingly
invited into this very small embassy
seven years after he had walked into
this building
assange finally left
he was immediately arrested again on
paper the uk government wanted him
because of this sexual investigation in
sweden from 2012 that investigation had
been dropped and yet the uk kept him in
jail because the u.s had formally
requested assange to be extradited which
basically means one country asks another
country to detain and send a criminal
back to their country to face charges
the uk would hear and assess the us's
request and in the meantime assange
would sit in the belmarch prison 45
minutes from central london
and that's where he is today when i'm
filming this
and he's not doing great he's been
examined by doctors and by the un
representative for torture
and they've basically concluded that
assange has experienced severe
psychological trauma because of his
isolation in the embassy and now in jail
including extreme stress chronic anxiety
intense psychological trauma the british
government of course disagreed with this
but the un has said that he has been
subject to psychological torture and
other cruel inhumane or degrading
treatment of punishment they also claim
that he's been medically neglected many
are calling this retaliation punishing
assange not legally but through these
really inhumane ways of not giving him
medical treatment isolating him in ways
that aren't warranted and now is the
moment where we need to remind ourselves
why this man is in jail not because he's
been charged with a crime but because he
published hundreds of thousands of
classified documents that an army intel
analyst chelsea manning gave to him and
the u.s wants to punish him so he's
rotting in a jail
waiting for the legal process on whether
or not he's going to get sent back to
the u.s to face these charges and to me
this gets to the most important part of
the story because what happens next
affects not just julian assange and his
story
but it could set a precedent
for all of us those of us who do
journalism and those of us who rely on
journalism to teach us about the world
what i want to do next is i want to dive
into this stuff
i want to walk you through these two
documents which are basically the us's
case against julian assange as laid out
by the trump administration in 2018 it's
daunting it's a lot of stuff it's a lot
of legal jargon but i've been through it
all and
i want to explain why this matters
okay let's do this
[Music]
okay
okay
so stick with me as i explain the legal
case against julian assange and what
that means for journalism
[Music]
the thing that the department of justice
focuses on is the events of 2010 when
assange received tons of classified
cables and war logs from intel analyst
chelsea manning who was previously
bradley manning has transitioned to
chelsea manning manning had a security
clearance
violated that security clearance and
ended up serving seven years in prison
for leaking all of this stuff to
wikileaks it would have been 35 years if
obama hadn't lessened her sentence so
the u.s focuses on this super giant leak
they start out by reminding us just how
many documents were leaked if you add
this up it's like over 700 000
classified documents we're leaked to the
world
and then they go into the actual crimes
what they see is the crimes there's 18
counts basically 18 instances where they
allege he broke the law in total this
would be a sentence of 175 years in
prison luckily we don't have to go
through all 18 counts to understand them
because they fit pretty nicely into
three main buckets hacking
aiding and publishing first let's go
into hacking the first bucket it's about
assisting the hacking this first
allegation is the least scary for julian
assange it basically says that assange
worked with manning to crack a password
on a government computer so that manning
could grab documents without being
detected incidentally it didn't work
they didn't crack the password but
the indictment alleges that he tried and
therefore it is considered a conspiracy
to commit computer fraud
which is a violation of this like 80s
era law called the computer fraud abuse
act it has a max sentence of five years
which for julian assange is not that big
of a deal given that he spent seven
years in the ecuadorian embassy evading
the charges okay so that's the first one
the least severe the other 17 counts
allege that julian assange violated the
espionage act
he has to answer for what he has done
wait what the espionage act hold on
you know i printed it off and read
through the espionage act i mean look at
that cool font
[Music]
the espionage act is really intense it
was passed in 1917 when we were fighting
world war one i'm going to read some of
it here whoever for the purpose of
obtaining information respecting the
states or to the advantage of any
coordination or otherwise it means
information concealing indefensible navy
yard submarine base fueling video
station
railroad arsenal factory holy smokes i
could keep going this law was meant to
punish people who were government
employees or members of the military who
had government secrets and went and gave
them to another nation that then hurt
the united states basically spies
espionage that's what it's about
espionage chelsea manning violated this
because she was a member of the military
she had a security clearance she
violated that security clearance by
using her privileged information and
therefore broke this law but julian
assange is not that he has never worked
for the us government he's never had a
security clearance he's an australian
hacker and activist it is very very rare
that the espionage act is used against
somebody who is not a government
employee who does not have a security
clearance so what is going on here how
is the u.s trying to use the espionage
act
against an australian
who didn't leak any information he
published information that was leaked to
him
so bucket two
i'm calling aiding or pelping the us
case here uses the espionage act to say
that indeed it was chelsea manning who
broke the law directly as an army intel
analyst it was her who had access to the
secrets she leaked to them but in u.s
federal law we have this thing that says
that if you aid someone in committing a
crime you are punishable
kind of as if you've broken the law
yourself yep got it right here title 18
folks crimes and criminal procedure
whoever commits an offense against the
united states or aids abets councils
commands induces or procures its
commission is punishable as a principle
if you helped out you did it too so they
use this law to say
yeah
julian you didn't do the hacking and
leaking but like you helped you aided
abetted counsel induced or procured and
willingly caused
manning to do this because you promised
that you were going to publish all this
stuff so that was sort of like
incentivizing chelsea manning to do this
and that is why you are being punished
under the espionage act wait this is a
giant deal this is a big deal this
logical chain that was just created
assange is being charged with aiding
manning a convicted spy because
he
published the things that the spy gave
to him okay
file that away for a second let's get on
to the third bucket in here the third
bucket i'm calling publishing
counts 15-17
and let's just read directly straight
here from the indictment the government
says that assange having unauthorized
possession of all of these reports from
afghanistan and iraq and the state
department etc which again he had sort
of induced manning to give to him they
then specifically allege that the crime
here
is that having all of these documents he
then communicated those documents
to the world by publishing them on the
internet whoa
the crime
is publishing that's the crime counts
15-17 are that he published something
[Music]
okay
we're done with the legal talk here
let's
talk about what this means
back to our three buckets here the first
one is the least scary to me did assange
try to help manning hack a password so
that he could remain anonymous
maybe the facts aren't super robust here
but whatever if there is evidence for
that and he gets convicted that's five
years in prison okay it's these other
two buckets that use the espionage act
that say that assange was aiding manning
because he promised to publish the
documents and then he went further and
committed three more crimes by actually
publishing them to all the world on the
internet
[Music]
let me explain something about
journalism really quick
new york times article about iran
doesn't matter whatever when you read
the international section or the
politics section of any big newspaper
you will see
quotes from
officials inside the government or
diplomats or whatever who request to
remain anonymous quote because of the
sensitivity of the subject what this
means is some government official talked
to the reporter at the new york times
and said hey i kind of want to remain
anonymous because i'm not really
supposed to be talking to you about this
but i think the information that i'm
giving you is for the public interest
and so i'm gonna do it anyway please
don't reveal my name and the new york
times is like okay cool and they publish
it that happens every single day all of
the time that is one of the most
important aspects of journalism is that
a journalist can have a source who feels
protected because they can remain
anonymous even if
they talk about sensitive or classified
information why because in our society
we value the flow of important
information for the public even if the
government has deemed it to be
classified so according to the
indictment from the department of
justice any new york times article that
is quoting a government official who's
talking about classified information if
the new york times publishes that
espionage i mean that's what they're
saying here
in fact tons of the leaks that wikileaks
published in 2010 and 2011
were also published by
der spiegel or the new york times or the
guardian oh wait but julian assange
isn't a journalist he's not like the new
york times reporter those are like
technically legitimate journalists
no
journalist is not a legally defined
status journalists don't enjoy some
upgraded version of free speech all
journalism takes place within the free
speech laws that all of us enjoy oh and
i don't really need to say this but
those laws those protections are really
really important free speech is what
keeps our society transparent it keeps
our government accountable it is
important and it is rare it's a new
thing like being able to hold
governments accountable is like kind of
a brand new thing in human civilization
it's not natural it's not guaranteed it
can easily go away so that is why i'm
concerned about this case
yeah go ahead charge julian assange with
the conspiracy to hack into a government
computer but as soon as you introduce
the espionage act into what he did you
start to play with fire
you're setting a precedent that could
easily be applied to the journalism that
we rely on every day to keep us informed
and to keep governments and businesses
accountable oh and i'm not the only one
who's concerned by this the obama
administration also worried that
pursuing assange would be
dangerous for free speech and journalism
so they didn't do it it was the trump
administration that really doubled down
and tried to get assange and charge him
and i mean
are we surprised so the bite
administration is sort of at a
crossroads like what are they going to
do are they going to push this are they
going to try to charge julian assange
with espionage well it turns out they
are moving ahead trying to get him
extradited to the us okay wait wait wait
there's been news we were making this
video we were editing it just because
we're interested in julian assange and
then
news broke the uk judge will rule
tonight on whether wikileaks founder
julian assange should be extradited to
the united states where a judge
basically said that it's totally legal
that assange be sent to the u.s to face
trial a judge approved the extradition
earlier today meaning he's one step
closer to being extradited now he will
probably appeal this it'll probably go
to the high court in the uk but like
he's one step closer how long could this
drag out sometime maybe not so much time
my whole purpose in making this video
was not to defend julian assange as a
person or even wikileaks as an
organization that's not the point you
can make up your mind on that the thing
that i hope i've persuaded you though is
that julian assange's legal case has
ramifications for all of us if he's sent
to the u.s and he's convicted under the
espionage act that will have major
ramifications on the future of
journalism i hope that is clear now so
over the coming weeks and months
this case will play out and
you know that i will be paying attention
to it and my hope is
that you will be too
all right that's it that's all i've got
for today um
this was a really deep dive we spent a
lot of time
on this and i hope it was helpful in
some way so thank you all for watching
for being here
lots more to come
um hopefully
videos in the future that
are not as
heavy and depressing as this one
but this one's important so
glad you watched it thanks for being
here and
have a wonderful day